hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to Fran oh now we're a tree
we met pelant racine at the king we
meant sexy legs we gave them all voices
and let's see if I can remember them
Elantras was my favorite I hope he comes
back I like talking in uh your legs
ain't is sexy hello sir
are you a guard are you gonna tell yes
is that all you have to say to me
Mountain cotrim do you know where the
mountain cool trim is I yes I definitely
know about it probably probably can you
tell me where it is
yes then tell me hmmm about it go from
is only in winter time winter time what
are you talking about
we have court with the time what do you
think
can't wait for winter I'm not just gonna
be a tree am I got a plant out for
winter oh you don't wait for you oh
that's right time is the hinge of our
reality or something like that time is
the perspective art of our of our
environment I don't remember them go how
a sorry but I'm no good at slaves I'm
just a dumb dog go down the stairs and
then straight you'll find a [ __ ] maker
he'll explain it I'm a bargain a bog
guard okay
carrying on thank you thank you thank
you sir
Waco Wright is in from my perspective or
your perspective what we got here oh
it's a map but I can't read
hmm okay so that means maybe thirsty oh
that's right in the journal that was
actually uh in the journal there was a
word guide I remember that right here oh
god I hope I see so they really made an
alphabet about this how do they even get
to here how did this guy do this Omega
no Mountain cart book library okay so I
guess I could go over this way but I
don't know I don't even have my pills
anymore
not that I need pills to make this weird
very odd clock where are the numbers has
symbols and collars but doesn't seem to
show the time time does work differently
I suppose
okay so I need to go find the clock
maker because apparently the clock maker
is gonna help me oh oh I'd like to
borrow that boat uh but again cuz I'm
just a tree and trees don't get what
they want hello another bug hello good
day living creature all good what are
you doing know enough about me what do
you do I'm smelling this flower
beautiful creation hmm are you waiting
for somebody I'm waiting for the lemons
to grow do you like lemons this is a
weird conversation and lemons are sour
for my taste
lemonade is what I will do with lemons
fourth customers of the bar oh and we
put some other stuff inside too so we
can fly if you know what I mean oh I
would like to say that uh uh uh uh not
for ten-year-old girls definitely this
is definitely not for children the bar
opened in fall and you will fly when
you're older you should come and hang
out though I suppose maybe I will it
sounds fun it was very obscure and I
have no idea what you're talking about
but enjoy that flower
it's a clockmaker maybe
hello oh my god they tore down my family
and boarded up this door looks like a
tropical party place how does that look
like oh it does look like a tropical
party place I was very confused for a
second there
all right I am very confused as where is
this the mountain that I need but they
said the mountain was only available in
winter this mountain top is very high
because it's the top good job there
kiddo good thing that tree grew your
brain strong all right then so we got to
find the clockmaker
oh wait didn't the guy say go down the
path and then go straight that would
make much more sense than going right I
forget things very easily sorry
everybody ah wow that is a buff root
hello buddy
how's it going over here how you doing I
can't read your prices so swindle me out
of all my money too good day for faviken
thread I'm at your service
thank you but I don't need any of the
moment hello and nobody seems to wear
clothes around here who's there who I'm
blind obviously me Fran can't you see me
oh now I see little you have four eyes
Wow
yes four eyes what are you selling only
the best plumbers in this entire land do
you want to smell it sure they look like
coconuts
it's Pumas eye I collect poo they're not
coconuts it's slow buses PO oh oh okay
all right then add white very yummy try
some it's good hehe I have to get going
now I don't want any of your clothes
thank you okay
are you sweating hi I'm Fran how are you
good day I'm pruder and I'm molding this
piece of iron who for what I didn't even
know you could get iron around here I
have to deliver a few clock pieces do
the clock maker oh I see so you can do
all kinds of metallic stuff sure we have
some ideas we can talk about and then
what I am I'm banging up into a metallic
goodness that's very good to know thank
you sir
keep working you know pop a mono that
thing I got a lot of problem in these
muscles to work out but if you need my
servicing you know where I am I don't go
nowhere
goodbye okay well that sounds clockey
hello what are you doing
mmm working on my clock I'm looking for
a withered on a mountain no miss I do
clocks I fix clocks I listen to clocks
clocks nothing but Clark's mountain
mountain children the mountain cotrim
only exists in wintertime otherwise it's
just a regular Mountain I can't wait for
a winner the king said the wizard would
be on Mountain cotrim you don't need to
wait for a winner to come that's absurd
time is an infinitely layered reality
here oh of course I'm 10 go to the big
clock and change the season where is the
clock but I tried it didn't work um go
towards the castle then turn to your
left when you see the stairs you'll find
a big clock on the tree good luck
oh they already saw that clock and it
was Birkin a Birkin clock that's a
disgrace hork Luke you have to help me
please fix it more me I'm begging you
I've got nothing better to do I will
literally beg here till the end of all
the infinitely layered realities of time
I never fix a clock for nothing
otherwise my last go into peace you want
some poop I can get you some poop what
do you mean I charge one big golden coin
per clock time it's gold you know
honorary coins I'm new here then no
clock will ever be fixed
please sir as a favor I need to go home
golden coin or nothing will be fixed why
it's awfully rude I will never change
unless I get paid holding the entire
existence for ransom good guy you are
okay so I got to find someplace to get
hello lady is there any news good day
would you like to read the newspaper
account read I'm tan don't you know it's
called a furnish are you a tourist hehe
yes I am a tryst my name is friend I've
never seen it before and I've never seen
a frien either welcome to a first day I
hope you will have fun here thank you so
much I have to go now goodbye okay then
I'm gonna find a court where am I gonna
find a coin you're old you're young
you're a snail you've got money I see it
ah whoa
lots of gold so do you want to play a
game I don't even care what you have to
say good day I'm gonna take all your
money what do you do the war is about to
start and I can't see meaning in the
meaningless uh okay I'm gonna back away
slowly till you make more sense
join me young one you'll be rewarded
with one golden coin if you can make it
back alive okay
all righty then oh come on us in the
velakis that's what was going on the
book the shadows in the light I get it
okay I get it I get it I get it I get it
board game immersing adventure I get it
looks blue I get it point if I win I get
it oh god I gotta read the rules first
place three of the same figures in a
diagonal horizontal or vertical line
wins
Wow so it's like connect three or
tic-tac-toe no that of course is
tic-tac-toe nevermind then I know what
that is okay time is golden I'm very old
a bit around a long time okay let's do
this let's play boy knows too well okay
what goes first wow it's been a while
since I played tic-tac-toe let me see if
I can remember my strategies before I
dive headfirst into this
I'm gonna be here forever unless I can
go first
nope never going first this is totally
fair and balanced yeah okay I got this
buddy bazinga bizango I got a go going
you want to play more I'll take all the
infinite layered realities of your time
oh I can't play more
okay I'll just play ball oh I'm going
first for once hey hey I got another
gold coin I'm gonna rob this guy all his
money seriously how much money is he
gonna give me okay that's enough I beat
the crap out of a snail that little
creature you're a master whatever
I'm leaving now I got enough money of
your giant pile of gold I'm gonna give
this to the clock maker he's gonna be
stopped being such a douche Oh Alice I
have won oh I thought I was gonna have
more than that why did I waste so much
time beating the crap out of a snail all
right what that I haven't fixed any of
your clocks
fix the clock oh but I thought you
wanted to coin to fix the clock oh yes
but you have to offer me the job first
do it and be polite Oh sir clock maker
would you like to fix my clock in
exchange for this piece of gold and in
the name of a time I beg of you except
by Allah of course that was an
incredible job offer very passionate I'm
really weird about things right let's go
to the big clock and fix it like now
would be good thanks buddy
oh you're a much weirder than either
you're all Wimbley and weird
why are you Wimbley and weird okay then
I'm probably gonna have to go back to
the blacksmith's if I can get some stuff
maybe you never know there's a very odd
clock where are the numbers mm you're
right this clock is very broken you can
fix it though right um go listen good
breath fire on second roof hmm good yes
sorry did you have an experience I
wasn't paying very much attention
what is it seems that somebody was
playing a dirty game around this
[ __ ] what do you mean someone was flying
with lemonade again rapscallions someone
broke it
mortal breaking a defensive clock why
would somebody break it Tomales winter
mountain cotrim the stones many reasons
miss Oh what are you talking about I
literally don't understand anything that
goes on this world I am ten Kemal is the
evil darkness they work for Rheem or the
terrible black I thought you would know
this and come on they're the only ones
allowed into this land the only evil we
have around it wouldn't surprise me
Rheem or wants the stones
what I don't understand it for what
purpose their sound and meaning of stem
in its kingdom and a stone during
wintertime this Remora giant black
monster with a goat mask a dead goat
mask I don't mean to be very specific I
just want to know generally is that
could that be him yes you've you've seen
it before you've seen the face of
literal death yeah you know way back
when in an insane asylum where I grew up
or where I was I think it's because of
him that I'm in this land I'm a human
you know uh-huh now I understand I also
need the stones apparently there are my
way back home for some reason someone
told me this is the king I think he was
a little crazy ah that is not why you
need to go into winter time ago to man
kill room will be yes exactly I have to
talk to the great wizard and borrow the
stone the more I talk about this the
crazier it sounds it sounds completely
bonkers Vic now I banged it with my
knobbly knockers it's good to go I'll
give you something that would make it
easy for you yeah oh cool it's a remote
control for the clock well that's handy
how did you do that it looks all
clockwork you'll be able to travel into
all four things in just a quick turn but
it's a prototype so may not work of you
too far away
I remember our time is an infinitely
layered reality though be careful I'll
be careful thank you very much you're
very nice clock maker guy please call me
cog whine all right mr. cog whine I'm
Fran by the way see you soon goodbye I'm
gonna go time-traveling now
apparently there's almost as
irresponsible as Doctor Who was what
happens if I actually use the thing ah
but in winter I saw shadows well winner
is what I need but I don't know if I
need to be around here for winter well
hello is the boat covered in snow maybe
I should be a little more careful about
this and kitty maybe you should be a
little more careful about standing on
the snow as we're traveling through time
at a million miles an hour okay so
apparently the library would be open to
now I'm pretty sure I remember that oh
my god everyone's gone why is everyone
just gone
nothing changed changed and kablooey
everyone's gone I mean I understand that
it's winter but come on people same
almost same hello who the hell are you
so your pet I thought oh it's a toy okay
feel like a person dragging it toy human
I guess people have baby dolls so that
does make sense I'm just gonna flip
through all the times in the different
zones just in case there's something
that I actually need all right you guys
keep on working into the wheel hours I
guess I you know I guess I just don't
need to putz around I go it's great to
the mountain because why else would I
need to be there
ladder okay I don't have any need to
climb that ladder definitely don't okay
oh hell do you think you are oh wow
what are you you look like a fairies in
my books but yours too feelings the
light of all material we are the velakis
I'm tired of this doofy boys I'm just
gonna go regular for now I'm giving too
many voices to do many things I'll never
keep track of it oh you're so very
shining you make me feel so happy so
very happy I'm sure that's not just an
illusion you're really evil look
creature one of the young one of the
young velakis will receive the shield
the shield of what why oh I thought that
said oh my god get back seriously
anyway peameal grow ohm began grant so
you're getting a shield to protect your
face from what exactly maybe from a
return of the darkness the mall at Mount
Malcolm soldier of the Sun creature from
the soil fruit from the seed let the
universe illuminate you with the truth
and be free all righty then where y'all
going I didn't understand any of that
it's so weird it's so weird
I want to keeping track of everything
nice and tidy but now it's just bizarre
we continue our paths to life may
freedom be with you my fren
sir or miss uh can you do magical things
and are you real and where am i and did
my mom and dad really die and why was a
Nancy asylum
the universe is already doing magic all
the time you were full of magic yourself
well I kind of want to know things I'm
tired of being a stupid Dan year old I
feel like you know everything we have a
lunch we are everywhere or something
whatever will impress you what are the
answers you looking for I want to know
who killed my parents and why is that
big monster hunting me because my theory
is that Fran bow somehow was forced to
kill her own parents like that would be
the really darkness of it the truth will
come to those who seek it your path
towards truth is immense you are living
in a world that turns its back to you
you're too fragile to face the truth
just now and too strong to let it go
okay but okay dear don't be sad we have
to keep going okay yes kitty you're
right oh dear you have to die sorry mr.
Chancellor the voice okay so there's got
to be something here aha
this moves the arms of the Loch is huh
so if I move the arms in a specific
pattern it's going to do something I
don't know what this is and I don't know
how to do it okay
I'm unclear what happens if I change the
seasons over here because I don't think
I could have gotten over here could I
I am at a loss not entirely sure what
I'm doing okay I'm gonna go back to
winter and I'm gonna go up the mountain
which is the original task that I was
sent out of here for and frankly I
should have done this oh hi well he was
creepy
hello is there a great wizard here
frankly I've been wandering around you
are weird looking hi how are you are you
the great wizard sir
grumble grumble grumble sorry sir I'm
Fran and I need your help
is this the mountain cotrim no one's
ever called the ballet excuse me can you
talk
sorry if I'm bugging you you have too
many questions that's good yeah oh sorry
sir the King told me you could tell me
what the King says we do okay so help me
i need the stones the stones are missing
in that I don't remember what they are
I'm too busy making lemonade that'll
make you fly through the sky every time
they seek I hide every time I hide I
forget so they can't be found
Hey you mean the black shadows sir or
are you talking about some other
experience I just want to know the
biggest answer of them all how does a
rabbit do it I saw it once a human did
it the rabbit came from an empty hand
wow this is the greatest question of
them all because if nothing exists then
nothing exists but if the nothing exists
then there is no nothing now I wonder
again oh wow sir why don't you ask the
person who did it oh I'm a bitter good
day what brings you to the great wizard
that means me just so you know I'm the
great with
good day sir the king sent me here for
the stones the stones I've been a long
time since somebody came around asking
frugal who's should I suspect you be up
to evil I make the most fantastic spell
of all time sir nobody could find him
hey I actually made the most fantastic
spell of all time
it made black goop shoot out of these
twins eyes up into the sky and then they
turned into ash and died
you know the black shadows have come out
sir I'm talking about something else for
a second there don't have to be here the
king told me that the stones would open
the door to go home the stones are happy
I only remember the full riddles that
are connected to the stone the
ten-year-old like you might just be the
brain that needs to solve them for
riddles that will unlock my memory only
when all four riddles are gaither
greatly I will be able to tell you where
to find them I've atoms these items are
sold in the reality then the only one
who can bring them back to me has a lot
of information sir so I need four things
to find five I didn't make you remember
let me show you okay I'm so down a
pentagram again a another hunt for a
spell this is the star of áfirstá boom
Quebec the great guide of the sky this
where I first discovered that they're
all like demons from hell and this is
like all their happy reality like that
South Park episode with the Happy Tree
Friends
hey hey blood orgy yay okay it's not
good
greatest caretaker of this land I forgot
to be talking about oh wow that sounds
great sir I think but there's a
pentagram on the floor but a man isn't
that not actually a bad symbol that's
like a pagan thing out of
I looked into it I'll give you the full
riddle written down the language of
everything the answer is always one item
okay
place the atoms on the star of a third
on their respective thimble and after
that I'll be able to tell you home bar
what Oh God
oh thank you very much great wizard it's
just a drawing of his dicks like just oh
thank you I I'll go get him right now
thank you sir Oh sir wizard the king
told me that you could make me did it me
till fly I think it's true maybe if I
get enough money they'll remember how to
do it you don't remember but I can't go
home like a tree I understand but I
killed you right now I have to recover
some of my knowledge I'm incredible
stupid rabble you can try to make you
human again after you find the first oh
that would be incredible I think yeah
incredible and green just like me and
I'll leave my home just try to figure
the rizal down I guess everything will
be fine
sir do I need something special to
become human but uh money lots of money
and spell smells that smells for the
spell
thank you so bring me your clothes and
we'll see how it goes
as the spell goes straight up my nose no
okay I'll bring them later okay I think
I got it
alright sir I'll bring you close okay
what the hell is going on with this so
much weird [ __ ] happening I'm cold as I
am but if you use me I'll be burning
hard huh I'm shiny as a Sun but I'll
never burn you perhaps a sour smile I'll
get you that's obviously a lemon Flo Flo
cold-blooded son let your body dance
through the rising stream an ice cube a
river a frozen river lighten Hollow I'm
the freedom of birds and the pen of men
the sky the sky are you talking about
late home oh the pen litter the feather
Oh feather literally the pen of men I
thought you meant like the cage pen cold
as I am hard but if you use me I'll be
burning hard is that like a coal or
something I don't know I have no idea
good on top of my own I guess I'm so
confused
I'm speaking in a lisp now hello the
other face hi whoa whoa whoa whoa pull
lamb Tris what the hell is that yes my
dear I saw it
what was it I think it's the shadows oh
dear I don't want to see them again
again yes kitty I've been seeing them
all over the place
everywhere and everywhere we will go
soon soon my dear
kitty can you make me a promise that
whatever happens you and I will always
be on the same side of course my dear I
promise well that seems like a weird
thing to ask of the kitty great now we
have to keep going going
okey-dokey then little bizarre
I swear that mountain has a face and I
didn't see it
okay so the four things that I need are
once again I need a coal a lemon
probably ice I have no idea and then a
feather brain steam like literally I'm
running out of brain steam okay so the
guy hello hi okay so the guy said there
we go lemons give me a lemon I'll take
that lemon thank you very much sir can I
take one of your lemons I promise I'm
not stealing them I'm sorry lovely the
lamb in the resources are quite limited
I can't lately take him I take old
lemons the basket can carry that means
all the lemons from the tree but maybe
not that one give me your lemons give
them to me aw come on Yin still from you
want to take your lemon I'm gonna steal
your lemons I'm gonna steal your lemons
hello good day little lady can you show
me your ticket please
how do I get one I don't know what all
the thirst assistants get a ticket why
don't you have yours yours oh I'm not a
citizen sir maybe that's why nots is and
that's new too new for me though sorry
little lady I can't let you literally do
it what a dick I wanna go get a lemon I
don't know it never happened before wow
they're so like it's sending me on so
many tasks you there's like ten million
things that I gotta do it's so weirdest
and it's so far removed from what was
going on how about this ticket is this
good enough yeah uh oh yeah it's an
exterminator I forgot about that okay so
oh god okay so I gotta get a lemon but I
got to do a question hello
hi Elantra sir okay bye
I got a feather though wait don't go oh
no he looked really bad kitty
isn't that the doctor maybe you can cure
himself I love so kitty he was so hurt
that he lost his feather his feathers
all black though but that's the first
little thing I guess I'm so confused
right now I'm so confused maybe you guys
can help shed some light on this cuz I
think there's the last one I'm gonna
record in this session so thank you
everybody so much for watching I really
hope you're enjoying this my mind is
just filled with so much what like I no
idea what's going on anymore it's so
weird I mean I want to get down to the
bottom of it but it's like what's
happening it was down to the scary and
now it's been like the happy but I know
it's gonna go back but I mean it's weird
like trying to discover all this nature
and laws of reality I don't get is too
much information okay so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always see you in the next video yeah
I'm ready
alright Billy
I'm ready so the idea is that we shut up
on defenses up here and go down hair
hide and then hopefully lock